docteur couach bonsoir merci d'être là
quand sort mais se voit alors je vais y
aller pas vraiment méthodiquement avec
les questions qu'on reçoit le plus
souvent là dessus d'abord la dose le
juste une précision on dit que c'est à
peu près le tiers de ce qu'un adulte a
reçu en termes de quantité c'est
exactement le tiers ses 10 microgrammes
plutôt que 30 bon échoppes comment on
est arrivé à
dire que c'est le tiers temps suffisant
pour les enfants on a fait des tests
quoi on a fait c'est pour ça que les
enfants n'ont pas été vaccinés en même
temps qu'ils adultes on a fait des
études de phase 3 phase 1 2 et 3 avec
des groupes de 5 à 11 ans il ce qu'on
faisait en fait c'est qu'on comparait le
profil de sécurité donc le pourcentage
d'enfants qui développait fatigue fièvre
et tout le reste la réponse immunitaire
donc le niveau d'anticorps qu'on
produisait suite à différents dosages et
l'efficacité et donc quand on compare
est d'aider dose de 30 microgrammes en
fait ils ont cherché la dose ils ont
commencé avec 30 mai se sont rendus
compte qu'il y avait énormément
d'enfants qui avaient fatigue fièvre et
tout le reste donc ils ont diminué à dix
et avec 10 au cours des études ils se
sont rendus compte que non seulement
c'était mieux toléré que le 30
microgrammes chez les 16 à 25 ans donc
il y avait un plus peu plus faible taux
d'enfants qui avait la fatigue la fièvre
et des douleurs partout mais qu'en même
temps on atteignait le même niveau
d'anticorps et qu en bout de ligne
l'efficacité et elle a même une dose de
30 microgrammes chez les plus vieux donc
on y on y voit toujours pour la plus
petite boucle la plus petite dose
efficace possible
et comme pour les adultes
on demandera deux d'orange ou oui tout à
fait parce que c'est parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on complète le
la barrière là contre la coved une dose
n'aurait pas suffi parce qu'on voit
entre autres à cause du variant delta
qu'une dose n'est pas complètement
protectrice c'est à dire que chez les
plus vieux là une protection autour de
30% mais qu'à deux doses on monte au
delà de 80 % contre les infections
symptomatique donc ça prend la deuxième
dose pour solidifier notre réponse
immunitaire bon alors je vous pose les
questions qu'on reçoit les lits les plus
fréquemment j'ai des craintes liées aux
effets secondaires possibles et beaucoup
de gens nous disent ça pour eux j'avais
des craintes oui mais pas trop mais pour
leurs enfants leur groupe on a des
craintes quant aux effets secondaires
puis c'est compréhensible parce que pour
les enfants depuis le début on dit la
coved n'est pas particulièrement sévère
donc ça prend effectivement un profil de
sécurité qui est très bon maintenant on
voit qu'avec les 3000 enfants qui ont
été vaccinées dans les études de phase
iii on a suffisamment de précision pour
être capable d'évaluer les symptômes
systémiques fièvre et cetera douleurs
locales et on voit que de ce côté là il
n'y a pas de problème je pense que ce
qui fait peur au gens cd des
complications peu plus rare mais qui
pourrait être plus grave par exemple
myocardique on a apporté chez les jeunes
jusqu'à l'âge de 30 ans maintenant ce
qu'on voit dans les myocardite c'est que
90% de ces myocardite leur sont bénignes
c'est à dire que un peu d'habileté les
noëls repos et ça s'en va que par
ailleurs il y en avait plus eu les 16-17
ans que chez les 12 à 15 heures donc la
jallère d'avoir un certain une certaine
protection qui a pas de séquelles et qu'
il ya des données émergentes qui semble
nous démontrer que quand on est ce parce
les intervalles entre les doses donc au
lieu de le donner à trois semaines comme
le manufacturier les recommande mais
qu'on fait plutôt du huit semaines comme
on a fait au canada depuis le début
était plus là il semble y avoir moins de
myocardite maintenant parce que le
profil de sécurité a l'air quand même
assez bon c'est à dire que d'un point de
vue fièvre et complications systémique
on en a moins que chez les plus vieux on
peut s'attendre à ce qu'ils aient aussi
moins de mieux car dit et je voudrais
que le dernier élément c'est que c'est
mieux qu'un article sur vienne en
général après la deuxième dose est que
les américains ont commencé à vacciner
il ya déjà deux semaines après la
première dose on n'a rien vu et que eux
devront donner leur deuxième dose à
trois semaines du fait que nous quand on
va être rendu à huit semaines là parce
que c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on risque
de faire on va voir quand même des
signaux long dont vous rassure et de
manière non équivoque il parlera
aux dimensions oui parce que pour
l'instant on n'a pas de signal qui vient
des états unis et par ailleurs on fait
une surveillance qui voit qui se
continue vous l'avez vu au cours de la
campagne de vaccination quand on avait
un doute que ce soit sur les thromboses
post astrazeneca où que ce soit et sur
les myocardite qui a toujours eu un
message qui a été lancée s'il fallait
faire des changements dans les
orientations les changements ont été
faits d'accord donc on ne cache
évidemment rien
je des craintes parce qu'il s'agit d'un
nouveau vaccin ça ça revient beaucoup la
wii mais c'est un nouveau vaccin plus ou
moins ça fait quand même un an qu'on a
vacciné des millions de personnes sur la
planète avec le triple de la dose donc
c'est de moins en moins un nouveau
vaccin et c'est rare qu'on ait autant
d'utilisation d'un vaccin avec un suivi
qui est quand même très bien fait les
systèmes de surveillance sont en place
donc c'est un nouveau vaccin parce que
ça fait un an mais c'est moins un
nouveau vaccin kion je pense qu'il faut
quand même prendre ça aussi on prend ce
qu'on a comme dom et puis les la
surveillance comme je vous le dis le se
fait où elle est l'expérience a été fait
à vitesse grand v il y en a quand même
multiplié les dos bon là c'est la
question fondamentale vous y avez vous
avez fait
vous avez fait
mention de ce soit tout à l'heure mais
ça revient beaucoup les gens dit je vois
pas l'utilité parce que les risques
reliés à l'aco vide ne sont pas élevés
pour mes enfants
ils ont raison toutefois la vaccination
de l'enfance et au delà il ya une
protection individuelle cercle 91 %
d'efficacité fait qu'il ya une
protection il n'en demeure pas moins que
plus devait y avoir de gens vaccinés -
il va y avoir de transmission
communautaire et c'est quand on va
réussir à diminuer cette transmission
communautaire là qu'on va pouvoir
commencer à relâcher un peu les mesures
qui sont en place je pense que les gens
ont tous hâte qu'on revienne un peu à la
vie d'avant mais pour arriver à ça on
n'a pas le choix que de limiter les gens
qui peuvent être infectés qui peuvent le
transmettre
présentement le groupe d'âge où il ya le
plus haut taux d'infection sa demeure
les 5-11 ans parce que c'est le groupe
qui est pas vaccinés et à partir de ces
enfants là il ya de la transmission dans
la famille perd les plus jeunes on a des
jeunes enfants qui sont hospitalisés
parce qu'ils ont attrapé à la maison
vers les plus vieux qui sont plus
fragiles vers les hymnes au compromis et
donc c'est ça ajoute je vous dirais des
barrières de protection pour ceux qui
sont plus vulnérables
donc quand monsieur le goût dit puis
l'heure répété hier que c'est une
excellente nouvelle la vaccination des
jeunes peu ça va nous permettre des bus
20-22 at-il dit de revenir à une vie
normale vous êtes d'accord avec ça c'est
un élément incontournable dans la
protection collective que de faire
vacciner nos enfants mais cette année
c'est un élément tout à fait important
maintenant il faudrait aussi que tous
les gens qui jusqu'à maintenant ne se
sont pas fait vacciner qu'ils sont
adultes à et chercher aussi cette dose
là je pense que ça va dans les deux sens
mais effectivement plus on a de
couverture vaccinale puis on est près de
là la capacité à enlever les mesures
jusqu'à tant qu'un nouveau variant
arriver là j'espère qu'il y en aura un
bientôt mais pour l'instant avec le
delta c'est quand même relativiser ce
qui circule présentement au niveau de la
planète jeu je vous laisse aller mais
avant l'autriche on parle à quelqu'un en
autriche plus tôt ils ont 10% 10 points
de pourcentage plus bas de vaccination
tout le canada par exemple et on voit
des cas cette même population qu'au
québec et l'écossé qu'ils 1000 par jour
est ce que ça vous inquiète parce que
vous croyez que ça peut venir ici que où
j'en est dans votre analyse de ce qui se
passe dans certains pays en europe mais
moi j'ai l'impression qu'au delà du fait
qu'ils ont une couverture vaccinale
moindre leurs mesures barrières sont
probables sont probablement moindre
aussi l'europe a quand même relâcher les
mesures de façon beaucoup plus à l'aigre
depuis l'été parce que ce qui n'a pas
été fait au canada et donc ça contribue
à l'augmentation
je voudrais que le but c'est vraiment
d'essayer de maintenir les infections le
plus bas possible pour qu'on pût samuel
se voir sans que ça reparte en fou après
noël parce que on le sait la noël on se
voit c'est intergénérationnel
interrégions si la transmission qui va
voir lui c'est là que ça va voir mieux
et donc si on part avec un taux
d'infection plus buggé en moins de gens
qui sont potentiellement contagieux il
va y avoir moins une transmission dans
le temps des fêtes donc le l'exemple de
l'autriche
n'arrivera pas nécessairement ici là on
est mieux protégé on a été plus prudent
savait pas dire que c'est la boxe ça va
arriver dans trois chemins disent ils
pas nécessairement mais savait pas dire
non plus qu'on est sortis de l'auberge
parce qu'on a une couverture vaccinale à
peu près décente si on relâche est où
maintenant c'est possible que ça remonte
ce qu'on veut pas voir c'est une
augmentation des cas qui se traduisent
par une augmentation des
hospitalisations
donc turquoise très clair merci beaucoup
nous avons parlé merci bonne fin de
semaine pour voir